yolande s'excuser le jour où se
retrouvent sur rack de l'olympique un
jeu vraiment incroyable on joue en fait
quelqu'un qui en fait on joue un cadavre
et et le but c'est de réussir les jo
dans l'api alors la première épreuve
cette passe au dessus de cette barre
ce qui risque d'être watts la glissade
fou comment on fait pour moi je peux
faire attendait du loews très bien voilà
premier rhum mondialement à perdre à ce
jeu un homme ou battre mais comment
faire écoute moi bien petit cadavre
si tu n'es pas content j'appelle un
nécromancien impute à mai mais s'est
passé une balle rebondissante 7 mai au
maroc où elle a réussi alors 100 m dash
allez tu t'envoles c'est n'importe quoi
we do you win 100 m eur dolls met du
poids cadets aux [ __ ] la vache
oh là là c'est complètement dur ce jeu
mais mais
et voudrait pas que cette cette
bande-son de lire un petit peu du
patrick sébastien je pense que patrick
sébastien s'est inspiré de cette chanson
pour créer ce pôle d'albums à avait
doublé de robin tu ce faire la fête et
là autour d'eux les serviettes
pour ceux qui préfèrent la même d'être
trop servile topo s'est complu le mot
guess what am et mec je suis la balle
rebondissante humaine ah mais j'ai
compris un truc assez ted hughes
rothschild j'avais réussi à tricher non
au nom mais met ko mais c'est pas
possible au mec est ce que quelqu'un
peut [ __ ] mais quel mec a fait la voix
au bout de ce à quoi est-ce que le mec
qu'on lui a demandé de faire la bouffe
du you lose il était comme ça
un roger stupide et roger you lose aura
là parfait mais quel talent quamissa
coup bien mais ça s'arrête jamais allez
on y retourne pas tout de suite
on peut mettre un petit stop motion sur
cette concentration in extrémiste in
extremis par l'ong jones y avoir fait
sauter loin c'est ça mien qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire et il se prépare
étrangement il saute montpelliérain
carrés avec du soleil uk ski ça faisait
là faut se battre
tiens merd faut que je l'envoie ailleurs
les quoi comment je fais al battar
capitale des esquives jeu quoi est ce qu
est ce que tu as compris diving ouarkoye
sautez sur du béton c'est quoi ces jeux
volley ball ah bah non mais là ça va
être vraiment dur à l'est quand vous
voulez jouer au volley avec un mec comme
ça moi moi je joue au volley je ne veux
pas dans mon équipe
ah non non tu dégages direct à cette
musique elle me tape sur les nerfs fait
aucun sens foule à balles c'est moi qui
vit de l'autre côté et j'arrive
la baie est ce qu on peut juste voilà
j'ai joué tout seul est-ce qu'on peut
être mais qu'est ce qu'il fait lui quoi
mais qu'ils aillent med
il est venu m'aider carrément aller mais
je crois honnêtement je crois que ça va
aussi mal au regard des noms c'est
n'importe quoi soccer elle est aujourd
foot qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qu'ils
achètent parce que je fais je sais pas
quoi ces essais mois à je fais dans ce
blog n'ont laissé moi non j'avais pas
mal couplé avec vous nos pneus pluie
derrière qui est pas du tout en état de
choc a fait des mois est un homme
violent et on s'embrouille avec laisse
moi mon année ouattara ado kwa temps je
me téléporte activités téléportation
watts au tam tam tam tam en bas tintin
tintin et si je marque comme ça et tu
veux faire de l'acrosport je ne veux pas
faire et qu'on soit avec toi dégage
bon bah c'est parti je vais devoir tout
me retaper a pas super voilà nous
revoilà au foot j'ai dû tout refaire en
mode all ah ouais le ballon merde à
bitam et sa wii le ballon est passé
non non non non non je veux pas d'un
couple et on avait déjà essayé ça voilà
et voilà il m'a refait buggé c'est bon
romain choix et c'est en effet sous peu
nombreux en défense on est beau
gentleman attendez je vais c'est de
mettre un énorme shoot au pif quoi mais
regardez il faut une pyramide quoi la
butte
basket ball
alors que moi wattecant voulait remettre
la balle dans l'info que j'aime là non
je veux pas les rejoindre leur
accouplement est arrêté tu avais ce jeu
c'est sa porte mais il fait quoi le vélo
il qu'est ce qui fait je suis caché tu
vas pas vu allez allez
il fait quoi le mec à droite est plus un
écran meilleur durant la partie
allez allez oust marque aux allées
marathon oui c'est parti pardon excusez
moi je suis pressé oui laissez-moi vont
aller comme ça voilà très bien will zyed
je suis premier oui on peut pas finir la
vidéo sans faire un petit
t'en penses quoi j'ai gagné et est
dégoûté un hacker dégoûté un mois je me
moquais perdu buggé
la famille tous les revenus en cours et
dans le
lombardi
donc elle ne survit